my name is Jordan Belfort the year I
turned 26
I mean 49 million dollars which really
pissed me off because was three shy of a
million a week
wherever I went I brought my family with
was all this legal absolutely not
in the movie hopefully they'll get this
cautionary tale almost like a blueprint
of what to do and what not to do when I
was in the bottom and everyone was
riding what a terrible awful person was
that I wasn't as bad as people were
saying and when I was on top I wasn't as
good as people were saying three for
lack of a better word is good I never
want to place blame on anybody
especially especially a fictional
character like Gordon Gekko then in a
looking sexy as hell on his $2,000 suit
with his private jet and he stood up and
said greed is good and I think a lot of
people kind of bought into that notion
that there's something noble about just
making as much as you can as fast as you
can and not really focusing on who gets
hurt along the way it's not true I was
taking enough drugs for soo beta pride
of elephants each day so I sort of
wasn't really focusing in the reality
I'm not making any money
on the books on the movie the only way i
wills if everyone got paid back then
I'll be happy to make the money but
until then I don't want to make any
money
as a broker trader you're really not
creating any and you're trading off of
the ingenuity of other people so it's
very easy to feel like there's nothing
tangible attached to your profit then
you haven't sort of emptiness to the
money you make you try to attach value
by spending my son decided to go in that
direction now which hopefully you know
capital and make sure he stayed on the
on the on the path of creating value and
focusing on the long term versus you
know instant gratification